all
ride through the city like BR I'm on a
mission to get it ride through the city
like BR if you ain't please don't get
and now
Brandon six
boy
sh yeah what is popping fam a little
later start we're about seven minutes
behind the ball here uh happy Monday
morning your boy was spent all morning
at the uh the shop having some issues
with the lightning uhoh here we go again
here we go again um it's probably the
fuel pump still so we're figuring that
out we'll get it we'll get it figured
out today we'll get it figured out
freaking today so right after this I I
head right back there so yeah man it's
hard to shoot content when that thing's
not running we got plans this week dude
yeah we sure did we got a lot of plants
coming up a lot of TRX content a lot of
lightning content but it's hard to do if
the thing won't run so it throws a
little wrench into things but we should
get it figured out today that's the plan
well we'll get it figured out um fresh
off the plane um from
Chicago Chicago dub Bears uh great time
in
Chicago um I can finally say I've I had
good pizza in Chicago at had Goos East
pizza and I like my pizza Sauced up I
like it Saucy and this pizza was super
super Saucy J sha ate five pieces in a
single night and those are thick pie
though that's not like five pieces of
like New York pizza that's like five
lasagnas yeah he ate uh yeah five slices
of lasagna it's it's a he ate an entire
casseroll to himself of lasagna it was
delicious though shout out to the comedy
bar man uh whenever I do Chicago it's
always in the suburbs in shamberg
because that's where the Chicago improvs
at and it's with traffic it's about
2hour Drive so that's why we decided to
try and find a venue that's in the city
and this place was we would walk to it
we'd stay downtown and walk to it so
wasn't freezing felt like uh Kevin uh
mallister from Home Alone out there it's
Chicago so Christmas it's just that
that's City just that's so weird you say
that I watched home alone this weekend
did you yeah my kiddos I introduced him
to home alone too last night nice
because they love hotels they love toy
stores that's all that movie is so they
absolutely loved it I took a straight
Redeye to make my son's baseball game
with they lost by two
runs what can you do kids are learning
travel ball team they're playing with
some good kids so what can you do but uh
yeah let's get to it man you got the big
UFC 296 the UFC is closing the year just
like they should this one is a big boy
this card is stacked even the prelims
are stacked but that main card is so
freaking
tasty possibly card of the Year depend
how these fights go down but it's has it
uh Written in the Stars this thing could
be by far the best card of the year um
yeah it's a good it's good time to be a
fight fan um this is the the last harra
for 2023 the UFC's had a great year it's
been a good year for uh all the people
in the fight verse you could say um yeah
this one's good and we we're closing out
the year we got a casses fight companion
this Saturday with Cheeto Vera Rampage
and myself for UFC
296 uh it's it's a big boy so we have to
bring in the big guest and that's what
we're doing man so uh it's going down
your main card kicks off with uh which
is kind of stole this The Narrative of
this crazy main card uh for reasons
outside of fighting you have a Vente luk
versus Ian Machado Gary that's kicking
the main card off that's how good this
card is and that card that fight I
probably have more excitement for than
any other fight on that card for uh it's
just a fork in the road for Ian Machado
gar this Prospect who is a once in a
generational talent and he's fighting uh
you know a tough guy with sente luk they
used to be uh training Partners there's
so much drama going into this fight and
I think if in Machado gar can weather
this insane [__] storm that he's dealing
with in his personal life and it feels
like the entire fight Community is
against this guy for me this is the one
that I star on this main card because if
Ian Machado Gary can weather this storm
and get a highlight reel knockout over
Vicente luk we will remember this moment
as he goes on to be world champion this
will be the fight that was the Make It
or Break It moment in this young
Fighter's career and there is so much
pressure on him there's so much pressure
there's so much noise and if he can
somehow pull this off which I think he
does if he can pull this off ignore all
the crap going on in his personal life
and all the hate that he's begin it's
gotten so bad he had to turn comments
off which is usually a bad sign but
again I don't think he's running his
stuff but regardless I think if he can
just somehow get over the hump and do
what he does best which is fighting
inside that octagon and if he can get a
knockout which I think he does over
Vicente luk this is it's going to propel
him to levels that he couldn't even
imagine and that's why I do what I do
that's why I do this show that's why I
uh continue to support the UFC this is
for these exact moments it's it's the
guys come- ups that I love it's what
keeps me uh involved in the sport it's
what um I get most excited for once the
guys that made it like Aon Edwards or
Kobe kington um once these guys are good
I enjoy watching greatness but to me
it's the come up the the Conor McGregor
come up if you remember those those days
those were they're so special there's
nothing like it in sports it's what
makes the UFC the best and Ian Machado
Gary is he's that guy and he has the
chance to pull that off Saturday night
um and I I do think he gets it done now
if he goes in there and gets absolutely
starched by viente Luke and looks like a
shell of himself he's not the guy and
somebody else to come eventually but uh
it would be a sad day in the fight world
if Ian Machado Gary um let this get to
him and let all the noise and the social
media and all this visceral hate get to
him and not show up I don't see that
happening in any facet I think Ian
Machado was built for this and uh I
think uh people that are talking smack
to Ian you're G to [__] around and find
out Saturday night and uh I I think he
wins in a convincing fashion and it's
going to be just a a moment we we check
in in Machado Gary's career and he's
going to on to do great things and it
starts Saturday night nothing that he's
done is bigger than Saturday night and
he has a damn tough opponent but he is
the perfect opponent a they've trained
together so he knows his tricks B viente
luk he's never been in a fight where he
doesn't get hit now the issue with that
and he'll he'll pull it off he'll win
but the issue with that is when you're
fighting a a sniper like Machado Gary
you can't afford to get hit and that's
just it's in Vicente LC's DNA that's why
we absolutely love this guy he's an
exciting Fighter um you know he he went
on that crazy run uh we what one four in
a row and then uh he got to Muhammad and
uh that's how good Bell Muhammad is Bell
beat him and then he lost to Jeff Neil
he got knocked out by Neil which is a
big win for Neil and then uh he did work
against uh uh dos angos for five rounds
but again um his type of fighting where
you know down that mouthpiece and Via
Cody garbrandt you know um but with a
much better chin I that is absolute
trouble for vente Luke in his Camp
against a sniper and Machado Gary and
you guys can tell how high I am on
Machado Gary He's if I to bet on anyone
be champ in the next 18 months it's uh
Gary and he has such a a big moment
where with all this this noise going on
in his life he can silence everybody
with a straight freaking head kick or
straight left or straight right or a
hook a killer uh Francis inano via alra
over him knockout he can get that done
man with with a with a sick uppercut and
it silences everything and it's then
it's just a thing of the past people
just like oh damn that's crazy some
people still bring up but it as Al Davis
said for the Raiders just win baby it
takes care of everything and uh I'd love
to see him shut everybody up feels like
the world is against him when everyone's
against like this especially once has
nothing to do with fighting when
everybody's against somebody that's who
I root for like you guys suck man
everyone's piling on them and oh this
and you suck your wife cuck this when
everyone's going that way I want to go
this way so uh I've never rooted harder
for someone than Ian Gary this Saturday
man because he he he has the skill to
pull it off and if if mentally he can
overcome this bro you're talking about
multiple time defending world champion I
think so we'll see no pressure Ian but
he knows the
pressure he knows the pressure I think
he he he definitely gets it done um the
the next fight on the main card Tony Fon
and Patty piml again there there's so
many stories with really with every card
with every fight on the main card
there's a and that's why I love this
it's just not two world class Fighters
it's all world class fighters on across
the board there's 10 of them right 10
worldclass Fighters and there's a story
each of these matchups have a story and
each fight has so much so much
implications for world champion title
shot bigger payday super stardom every
one of these fights is such a big deal
when you look at Tony F and Patty piml
again there's a for fork in the road and
this Fork has been in the road for Tony
Ferguson but it's also a fork in the
road for Patty piml
because you know most people think Patty
lost his last fight against Jared G
Gordon and he's gotten a lot of hate for
that but he again he's this young kid um
he says some of it did get to him like
when Rogan said he thought he lost the
fight and so he wants to prove everybody
that he is the real deal but you know
Patty penlet a lot of people you know
root against this kid because they think
he's had it too easy and he doesn't
deserve the fame that he's getting which
I disagree this kid is an absolute
freaking star now is he a world beater
right now no but that's he's not
supposed to be right now you got to
realize where he's at in his career he's
not supposed to be you know a top 10 guy
right now so you know he stumbled
against jar Gordon again he's gotten all
this hate and he's good at managing that
and he's a superstar for that reason he
does well with whether he gets you know
praised or whether he gets hate so
that's part of being a superstar is
dealing with all that noise and not
letting it get to you not changing who
you are I think Patty piml let's Built
For This the issue with Patty piml is
his star is bigger than his experience
and skill set right now so for him we
want to keep this momentum going he's a
bartool guy so he has the push from
bartool which is massive Dana White
loves him he's the face of Liverpool so
he has all this going for him but you
know people don't like when you know you
get over when you get over on a guy like
Jared Gordon who's this grinder and he's
beloved by fans and people thought he
lost that fight and he probably did it
was close but he you know he probably
did so now this next
one it's tough for Patty piml because
he's in a no-win situation even if he
gets the best version of Tony
Ferguson who's training you know with uh
David gogins which we'll get to but even
if it's a a a good version of Tony
Ferguson people still aren't going to
give Patty the credit he deserves
because you're you're talking about a
Tony feron which most the people
watching this show and the people in
this room remember when Tony feron was
the baddest 155 on the planet you know
it was was he him or khabib they were
supposed to fight many times he didn't
come to fruition all good but Tony at
one point was the baddest man walking
the planet so we know that version and
and Patty's not fighting that version
Patty's fighting a guy with one two
three four five six
losses so again for Patty if he goes in
there he knocks him out in 10 seconds
we're like yeah dude it's Tony Fon
that's his sixth loss in a row seventh
loss in a row good good job next so this
isn't going to do much for pat patty but
hurt him if this is a competitive F
competitive fight that goes the distance
it's going to be bad for Patty so you
know I get the UFC's traditionally known
for when a guy of legendary status like
Tony Ferguson and they got the up
incomer they're GNA say all right beat
him to Dethrone this guy and take his
fan base and move on you can they've
done this a million times but this is
the worst one I've seen yet because no
matter what Patty does he can't really
win people over over with this so it's a
very very risky fight for Patty he's not
going to gain any more fans he just has
to show that he can dominate a guy like
Tony
Ferguson T Tony is tough man you know I
know he's fallen on hard times he's a
shell of himself and no matter what
happens
here I don't want to say it should be
Tony's last because I do think if Tony
were to win this fight there's a world
where Tony gets the Conor McGregor fight
I could see something like that
happening because Tony and Conor are
supposed to fight for a hot second Conor
is going to fight Chandler next at
probably UFC 300 or maybe a little later
but there is a good chance and as much
as we love Conor there's a good chance
Conor loses that fight so what do you do
with Conor he's not gonna fight these
big time dudes anymore he can't it's not
there we need to get him a win a Tony
fergon fight makes a lot of sense but
Tony has to win so if Tony wins what a
great last fight you finally get that
elephant fight that golden elephant that
green elephant named Conor McGregor it's
a good fight for Connor it's a good
fight for Tony it makes sense a lot of
people would tune in everyone's familiar
with Tony everyone in God knows Connor
and he needs the win it'd be a good
fight all the way around so for Tony if
he loses yes end of the road 100,000%
this thing's
over but what's waiting for Tony if he
were to win is I think of Conor McGregor
fight so the again Fork fork in the road
think about that those two extremes if
you lose to Patty piml a guy who's not
even ranked this whole thing is over
your ridiculous Hall of Fame career is
over if you win waiting in the shadows
is the biggest fight of your life even
though you've lost six out of seven
fights if you're were to win this one
you've lost six out of seven and you
still get the Conor fight and you know
what he's earned it who would be mad at
that he's earned it you wouldn't watch
Tony fergon Conor of course hell yeah
you would wouldn't that be great they've
been they were supposed to fight a few
times now they've been calling each
other out he he keeps calling them
McNuggets too yeah yeah so yeah they
there's a lot of heat there yeah but
that what a great sendoff for Tony F in
his career he deserves that so I'm
conflicted on this
card with a bunch of these fights my
heart wants this guy to win but my
head's definitely saying this gu to win
so I'm not I'm not batting on this card
I'm not I like too many the guys um you
know vente luk he's been on food vente
luk is one of the nicest guys you will
ever he is so freaking cool but I don't
know him Machado Gary but just as a
fight fan the re I want I want to see
him win doesn't mean I don't like vente
Luke I just think cend LC had his run
and the Machado Gary's turn when it
comes to Tony Ferguson Patty piml I I
don't see Patty pimit lose I love Patty
Patty's one of my favorite Fighters
again he's on the come up I love that
story that's what I do this for I I
would love to see Patty win and get
another big fight and prove all these
people wrong and his striking gets
better
um but again I love Tony love because
Tony wins I really think a Conor fights
in his future I'd love for a guy that's
put in the work and all the years and
you know probably suffering from CT and
some you know degree and the and his
sendoff is a a mega fight against Conor
McGregor that he's always wanted he
deserves it man he has kids he has a
family he's put all the work in he
deserves
it that'd be a great fight for the
casuals and the hard too yeah so it
would be a great fight for sure but do I
want to see Patty loose no do I do I
want to see Tony loose no so it's uh you
know I don't I don't want to pick that
card now did I bet I bet Brian Callen
who a [__] I bet Brian a lot of money
uh Tony Ferguson could win cuz you know
even though he's lost six in a row Tony
Ferguson's a Savage and training with
David
gogins I like that but it it
just it doesn't check the it doesn't
make me feel good
because the last thing on my mind when
Tony's going into the oon is I hope he's
in shape has any has it in the history
of Tony Fen fights has everyone went oh
he looks out of shape never also this is
a three round fight if it was five
rounds I'm like oh man Tony with a even
better gas tank for sure gonna win it's
three rounds Tony can do three rounds he
does need a training camp so having
David gogins again he Tony's never been
mentally broke I can understand if if it
was a guy like Patty piml let's say two
fights from now cardio's an issue he's
on a two-fight losing skid and he just
needs to get his you know that oomph
back that that kind of dog in the back
he sent him with daveid Goggins but Tony
that dog's never left his body left his
chin
left David can't really help with that
stuff so as much as you know I posted
him training with David and I love it
and I was like definitely picking Tony
now all jokes aside it's uh for Tony's
it's going to be head movement and you
know I I think mixing it up more not
relying so much on those that weird kind
of unorthodox movement
uh anymore at his age and um Tak down
the fence Tak down the fence is kind of
you know it's not great there but he'll
always embrace it because he encourages
the the Transitions and will catch
people in dares and triangles and head
and arm choke so um for him it's going
be taking advantage of Patty pilet
striking Patty pilet striking is nowhere
near Tony his especially his defense
Patty Pet's defense of striking is is
very uh amateur he and again he he has
to work on that and and he's gonna work
on it I'm sure that we're gonna get a
better version of Patty pet but is he a
finished product no is there holes in
his games absolutely but that's why this
is great so we'll see what version of
Patty we get we'll see what version of
Tony we get but the implications for
that fight are insane for Tony it's
either you're done and you're watching
the UFC like me on the couch for the
rest of your life or in your future as a
Conor McGregor fight Jesus Christ
for Padley o lose this one man it you
know he's still young enough where it's
it's not the end of the road but it
definitely hurts so you have that Tony
feron fight where it's win or you know
it's over but for Ian Gary you got to
win you know and then in the the third
fight shot uh Wonderboy Thompson this is
a title Eliminator fight the the the
winner of this I would assume fights uh
at welterweight next for the title shot
we've always knew he was coming um he
just walks very slow to get to the title
this dude is not very active um you know
he's undefeated all finishes he's
fighting a 41y old Wonderboy Thompson
Wonderman Thompson and um you know this
is the UFC disciplining
Wonderboy that's exactly what they're
doing he came out you know he turned
down that fight and then uh he came out
was like he still haven't been paid and
the UFC is like all right dude you going
to make us look bad say less here's shot
it's a terrible match up for him it's
awful
awful so you know you would assume this
is the title Eliminator fight if Wonder
Boy to win for sure he deserves it I
mean that's a no no-brainer and for shot
they they're just waiting they need a
reason to get him in the title picture
this would do it this would do it now
again so much uh implications here cuz
if Wonder Boy loses he's on the wrong
side of
40 he just lost a fight you know that'd
be three out of his last
four so here's Ronda boy's record right
here that's what I'm saying if you lose
this one that's three out of four but
yeah you know he beat Kevin Holland they
lost mohhamd he lost Gilbert Burns so at
41 you're way back in the
queue there's a lot of young cats you
know that because it's over man yep
so that's interesting to me it's over
again fork in the road I I keep saying
forks I don't like forks I use spoons
when I can I don't like forks I hate
forks I like spoons spoon in the
road um and then you get to your co-main
event probably the the best matchup
um as far as stylistically as far as
skill set probably the the most even
matchup at a world class level on the
card especially the main card is the
co-main event the world title fight and
they only fought I think two years ago
and Roy Roy Val got choked out but it
was a competitive fight good fight a lot
of scrambles but
um it's weird because the most
competitive high level fight on the card
for two guys in their Prime it's
probably going to be the least watched
fight or talked about fight it's just
the way it is we Housewives of the UFC
and pantan Brandon Roy Roy Val are just
you know they're they're not the hot
chicks in this in this episode just is
what it is they're they're the friends
of the hot chicks we like yeah I know
them I like them I'll watch it but I
can't wait for the hot chick with big
tits in the main event you know that's
how it
goes um this one's interesting because
again they they they fought recently
Brandon Roy Val lost and then now he's
been on this freaking war path man he's
been on a path you know he he lost to
Pantoja is his last loss that was August
21st
2021 on a Fight Night Jared Canon over
scast him and then he's gone on to to do
work he's won three in a row so he's
earned it but he's lost you know to
Brand Moreno he lost to panta so the top
of the top though yeah the tip of the
spear guys but um you know now he gets
another title shot he's a Colorado boy
so you know who I'm rooting for uh but
again Pantoja story is fantastic MH when
we got on the mic I was like do you love
me now dad everyone's like whoa
heartbreaking let's look into that again
here comes Real Housewives
MMA you didn't care about him till you
got on the mic and talk [__] to his dad
wait what happened you You See Me Now
Dad it's all took we're in oh you have
father issues we're in now we care how
you fight he's a ridiculous fighter do
you care about me now dad Uber F you
we're like wait
Uber like driving for Uber too in the
UFC yep that story was funny cuz people
like this is ridiculous this world class
fight is driving for Uber it's like yeah
he didn't fight for 3 years UF UFC can't
pay you like that's the gig you gotta
fight that's like me being like I still
want my money from podcasting not doing
podcasting this is ridiculous like we
gotta podcast dude you know you gotta
fight dude UFC didn't want you to drive
for Uber but also you gotta fight that's
your gig uh but that's a great fight
great fight best fight in the card
stylistically everything you know I know
they're smaller so you guys don't care
but phenomenal fight uh and then the
main
event again there's so many storylines
into this this Main Event Leon Edwards
Kobe comton finally it's here people
have their opinions on if Kobe should
even be in the situation you know he's
been not that active um go to his record
chin sorry dude yeah that'd be great uh
you know was he's two and two his last
four he only loses the very very best uh
in
damn near eight years January 1 it' be
eight years he's only lost to one
opponent named Kamar
Usman that's how good this kid is he
beats everybody else not named Kamar
Usman he steamrolls everybody has not
named Kamar
Usman um he does a great job at keeping
his name in the
headlines um he plays a character you
know people at my show come up to me
dude Kobe Leon who got I hate kobby man
that Trump lover him like saying you
hate Kobe because the things he says is
like hating The Undertaker and the
WWE you actually think he comes from the
grave that's it's it's the exact same
thing it's just a character he's the
nicest most respectful dude I've met in
the sport it's a character hate to tell
you guys now he'll never tell you that
and I think for for Colby too it's just
a way to his style is not the most
exciting
but it's a way for him to get in these
Mega fights and keep his name in the
headlines and make a lot of money you
know heavy lies the crown he gets a lot
of pressure he gets death threats bomb
threats the heavy lies the crown but
it's worked out for him in general he's
not in this fight if he didn't have that
Persona not a chance being as inactive
as he is some of the you know outside
oon issues you know the lawsuit with Hy
mozal there's not a chance they put him
in here if he didn't come up with this
character that he plays you know so um
I'm a huge Colby
fan I just get worried because uh he's
not active and not being active than
fighting a guy Leon Edwards who has been
active and who has also beat your guy
your Achilles heel
twice you know that last one it was a it
was a closer fight but he definitely
beat him man you know he definitely beat
him he looked good and lon's getting
better and we're seeing him get better
in front of our eyes he he's a you know
world class talent for Colby we know
exactly what he's going to do Saturday
night there's GNA be no new wrinkles he
has his bread and butter he doesn't want
to you know work on his striking he he
knows what he he he he has a limit with
his striking he knows he has a gas tank
from God and he pushes forward and he
does his thing he looks for takedowns
and tries to break
dudes for Leon Edwards he's had the
perfect opponent to get ready for Colby
he's fought Camaro kamaro Usman he's
been focused on Camaro Usman for
literally a year straight and he beat
him
twice so the odds are not in col's
favor sucks to say I I I would love for
Kobe to win this fight the story would
be fun he's a good character for the
sport him getting the title he just runs
with it he'll get a lot of eyeballs um
so it's a very tough fight for Colby
it's a very very tough fight for Colby I
think uh he's going to implement a lot
more wrestling a lot more grappling than
Camaro did um but but again he he's
going to go for those takedowns and he
does apply pressure and he uses striking
the stad up his
takedowns the issue with Lon is he's so
much better at striking than all these
wrestlers who adapt to striking it's
lon's language it's his first language
when it's these wrestlers second
language so Leon's going to have such an
advantage and the problem there is he
has such an advantage on the feet and
he's been working and his team's been
working they know that's the key heel
when it comes to Elite Striker is
getting taken down so he's working with
high level wrestlers and his Tak down
defense getting better and better and
better and he's been focused on these
wrestler via strikers for the how many
years now getting ready for it and he
had the perfect opponent to get ready to
beat a guy like Kobe and Kamar Usman
it's if I'm saying all this being a Kobe
KT fan if you're a Kobe kton fan it does
not look good it doesn't look good but
I'm rooting for him again wouldn't bet
on it not g to make any picks I know who
I want to win is he gonna win it's not
looking good it's not looking good can
he do it absolutely absolutely but would
not put money on
it and the one the one excit there's a
few exciting ones on the prelims uh in
in Josh EMT and Bryce Mitchell BR which
a replacement yeah that's a phenomenal
fight tough fight for Bryce has to get
him down Josh hits like a Mac freaking
truck
dude Cody garbrandt Brian kellerer um
awesome yeah great fight Casey O'Neal
lipsky how dare you put Alonzo menafield
and Dustin jacobe on the early prelims
let's go to the UFC website just to
double
check because what on Wiki yeah usually
Wiki's more correct though so let me go
back a little bit
here all right
so early
prelims yeah you're right yeah that's
rude Andre fely too on the early prelims
fely Al is a phenomenal card good luck
getting freaking uh a bonus on this card
man it's going to be
Saucy anybody in here want to bet who
gets the bonus I'll tell you who I put
my money on
oh you guys go first okay out of all the
card yeah
man this one looks good but I'll go
first Patty you're taking Patty
yeah yeah they usually always give him
bonus and then bar gives an extra bonus
that boys balling chin I'm thinking hold
on let me look through it one more time
you know let's go to Wick you get easier
see everything just pick somebody Chad
I'm picking right now uh honestly I
think for some reason shaf cot and and
Wonder Boy Might Be Crazy M yeah but you
who who's going to get the bonus oh the
bonus no both of them you think they
both oh
yeah I'll take Ian Gary for the bonus I
think he get a head kick knockout and
the UFC knows all the pressure Dam
that's specific y head kick knockout yep
dope all right we have what's the money
I don't know 20 bucks how about how
about lunch you have to buy lunch at
that place at the let's go let's do
sounds good to me you got to buy lunch
at the 6 sounds next
week we just ordered and you bring it
here you you got to go you got to go
pick it up you got to walk there you got
to walk there too busy you're too bus BR
get it and then walk over here I'll take
uh Gary gets the bonus all
right well makes it more fun now now
hold on chin the'll prob so to make it
fair you you got to pick one person then
you got to pick one person or to be fair
you could you pick one fight so you want
to open it up if you're just going to
pick a fight you have shot Wonder Boy so
if Wonderboy knocks him out with a head
kick and gets a bonus you still win even
if you think shot's gonna win it doesn't
matter or if shafkat wins in this like
it's a back and forth It's Fay the night
and they get a bonus they both get a
bonus you you win so I have more odds of
winning then well because then then no
because then vente if vente luk and Ian
Gary is a you know a slocker and they
get five the night I win okay all right
fine so you just just go with one fight
so it increases our cool so I'll take
vente luk Ian Gary you're taking sha cot
Thompson and you got Patty and Patty
Tony okay I think I think I guarantee I
think Casey's gonna win this one dude
yeah Casey has a good chance so you if
one just one guy gets the bonus you win
if it's five the night you win so
there's multiple ways to win I like it I
mean I would somebody's we pick the
three main fights yeah but it's always
it's it's always the safest BET's always
the main event cuz if Lon Edwards gets a
a knockout it I mean that's it or if
Colby get gets a submission or something
that if you're the main event you're
getting that performance bonus 100% yeah
but they do give multiples out so it
could be like an oper win for you you
get a bonus you get a bonus and then
nobody's buying
lunch this card's so goddamn good yeah
dude top to bottom yeah man and we have
a cbass fight campaign starts live 700
p.m. on thick boy YouTube with Rampage
Jackson and Cheeto Vera it's going to be
a fun one yeah dude and speaking of UFC
296 oh if you're going to watch the
fight command 700 PM live Pacific Time
UFC 296 with me and the boys you can
also watch it and make Bank bro that's
right something special is going down
UFC 296 and draftking Sportsbook is
helping you come out out on top in this
epic bout between Kobe Covington and
Leon Edwards you also got Ian Machado
Gary you got vente luk you got freaking
piml Tony Ferguson there's so many fun
parlays you can do so many freaking prop
bets you can do this is the best card of
the year and it's going down this
Saturday so watch and make bank with
DraftKings download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app right now use the code
shop show new customers can get $150
instantly in bonus bets for betting just
$5 only on draftking Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
UFC with the coach shop show the crown
is yours who wants to do this gambling
problem call 1800 gambler or visit ww.
one800 gambler. net in New York call
8778 Hen or text heny
467 369 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call 888
78977 7 7 or visit ccpg dorg please play
responsibly on behalf of booill Casino
and Resort in Kansas 21 plus age varies
by jurisdiction void in Ontario bonus
bets expire 168 hours after issuance c d
d n dk.com for eligibility and deposit
restrictions terms and responsible
gaming
resources all right we did it we did
it this episode of the shop show is also
brought to you by the best freaking
katom on the planet we talking about
happy hippo hippo hippo hungry happy
hippo it's a perfect gift that just
keeps on giving talking about your brain
we're talking about getting you that
freaking Limitless pill it comes in
powders tablets gummy Taffy uh highly
concentrated shots they they K dips that
I use all the time it's happy hippo
katum the wild wild west of katum don't
just trust anybody trust the OneStop
shop it's happy hippo.com promo code is
thick 23 you get 20% off for a Life
share with your friends your family your
mom Uber Uber Eats Postmates UPS FedEx
whoever you want y'all can all get this
bonus all you got to do is go to happy
hippo.com promo code is th23 let's get
back to the
program all right uh do you want to
cover any of the fights that happened
over the weekend dude how about our boy
I I should have wore a shoes Cleo rry
sent me some amazing kicks some thick
boy red uh dunks um Cleo rry Anthony
Smith yeah what a story because remember
Cleo was going to retire remember he was
out he was thinking about getting out
he's like this probably my last one
there's a lot of retirement talk now
here he's right there in the light
heavyweight title contention
conversation because Anthony Smith was
there too if Anthony Smith won this one
because him and Alex Pier have a history
you know going back and forth I think
Cleo rry you look at the light
heavyweight standings he's right there
he's right maybe one away I could see
them giving it to him cuz Cleo versus uh
Pier is a fun fight a lot of guys are
hurt a lot of guys lost C's right there
let me see the light heavyweight uh y
rankings so Yi no Jamal Hills off the
out for a second for a variety of
reasons um mamad kick rocks uh Yan no
he's out injured yep rat kick coming off
the injury kry Johnny
Walker Johnny Walker has a fight coming
up against mamed so that doesn't that's
not going to happen Anthony Smith was
eight oir not happening Ryan span and
then Round
Tree yeah love to hear the argument why
round tree doesn't deserve a title shot
you tell me you want to watch Round Tree
versus Alex pierra especially if Alex
wants to come back soon too the balls on
freaking K to call freaking Alex yeah
yeah well it makes sense who who else
you can give it to Anthony Swift's with
eight so Cleo rry is gonna go number
eight Johnny Walker's booked for a fight
and Racket just calling out um Yuri and
they're they're they're like AR with
each other has been out for a hot second
so he's not getting a t shot coming off
at 5 um mmed at three is tied up Yi they
just fought Jamal Hills having legal
issues and his
Achilles or yeah love to hear
it why why w't you give him title shot
you'd be excited great story youed to be
lbs you know what that's like Chen I
yeah kind of and he's so jacked dude
like insanely jacked Jack City great
dude too yeah
yeah I was I was just happy to see uh
our boy CLE do the damn thing yeah and
then remember the the finishing thing he
was like yeah he waited yeah he waited
for the ref to just see to make sure
Anthony was out now if you're Anthony
Smith what'd he
do I think when he was talking on his
broad on his show he was saying like
yeah I think he was saying like you know
with other opponents that he has to
worry about different things that they
do with um with um with KH it's like one
thing it's like you know the Striking
leg kicks and you know and he's like he
sounded like he was going to beat him
like confidently sure and then he got
beat Bad by him so yeah uh I don't know
I think he he has so much other stuff
going on he's an analyst has his podcast
B yeah and you're back to the queue now
yeah so just and there's a lot of
contenders you know like I was saying
there's a lot of contenders they're
they're tied up or they're injured but
there's a lot of guys in front of them
so hope prob drop out of the top 10 now
so he good for a while Smith's age is he
going to does he want to win three
fights light heavyweight you're about
you're always about two fight if you're
in the top 15 you're two fights away
from a title shot so he has to win two
those those two fights are going to be
tough so 35 to him I support him
whatever he wants to do but he has so
much going on this a good thing when
every time why he has other stuff going
on yeah it's a good thing what but he
said he's just he has an itch always for
that title shot so who knows if he's
that hungry for it now if his itch is
just to fight for a title and not to you
know fight
any it's going to be tough yeah that's
why it's tough right
now this be very tough uh so once again
one Championship delivers I saw this
entire card it was insane dude the MU
all Muay Thai card and that's what
that's that's why I'm telling people
it's it's it's the highest level Muay
Tha and they have 4 o gloves on so if
you're ready for some Knockouts this is
youro it's crazy dude ready for this the
first this is the main card one two 3 4
five six the first wait one two three
four yeah the first so first of all
seven out of eight fights on the card
were starts Knockouts and then the one
fight our boy Joe which was fun as hell
so fun with the unanimous
decision seven out of eight Knockouts
dude D were getting stared and it's not
just heavyweights you know when you see
an all heavyweight card like yeah of
course that's what it is uh flyweights
there's 120 PB dude that got dropped
with a body shot the 150 PB dude just KO
Central dude insane and how big is that
Roman cat that Swedish monster 6 seven
god dog and fast as hell like yeah that
was great man it was so much fun to
watch yeah we had on the Green Room in
Chicago best Green Room we've had
Chicago
yeah uh here's a quick one with boxing
so Devon Haney fought uh Regis PR gry
yes over the weekend and he won every
single round unanimous decision Dro him
too that was a great fight and now uh
Ryan Garcia's calling out Devon Haney
that's the fight that's a blockbuster
fight Devon Haney's the
man boy is bodied up in that picture God
D they're both actually pretty jacked in
that picture but oh not this one uh
let's
go so Alex paa posted a
picture of Anthony Smith getting knocked
out and he goes oh that's that was a
good fight and it's kind of messed up
and it's obviously because they had beef
you know going on from before was
because Anthony Smith was saying oh when
he come up to light heavyweight we'll
see if his power stays I don't think it
will but you got to realize he wants to
fight him so he can't just be like go
he's the best he's going to destroy guys
I'd love to fight him so these guys and
it's just Fighters Comics same thing
they're so sensitive so for Alex it's
like you know dude he wants to fight you
so of course he wants to get your
attention that's how he does it he down
side of that is when you do that and you
lose this is what this is the
blowback yeah um and plus he was saying
it because he's a you know a commentator
he's Alex just felt like he was just
always against Alex but I mean yeah if
he wants a fight what I'm talking about
this guy goes he literally said he
doesn't have that much of a size and
power Advantage at 205 in comparison to
185 how are people hating Smith for this
yeah I'm it sucks to be a commentator
and a fighter cuz and a fighter that
wants to fight someone in your same
division right so you got to cover him
and everyone's jacking them off and you
want to fight him you're like we'll see
I don't think he power translates the
next you know he's like this guy hates
me like whoa
hey yeah so this is pretty crazy too so
Cal the csac the California State
athletic commission they're
they're they're okay now in 2024 I think
in April 2024 with uh bkfc and slat
fighting they're allowing slat fighting
they're approving slat fighting it shows
you how bad the state needs money that's
the first thing it also shows you how
big of a joke the commissions actually
are they're not there for fighter
safety I mean it's it's this would be
the same if you think politicians are
looking out for your best interest no
they're looking to pad their pockets the
commissions are the exact same it's all
corrupt it's all just [__] what
commission would sanction slap now I
have no issue with slap fighting do your
thing slap Fighters I hear it's really
entertaining person all good do your
thing more power to you but to say it it
should be sanctioned by a legit
commission's insane we all know we all
know what's going on here the
commissions it's corrupt as [__] dude
it's definitely money yeah it's all
money but bkfc I get it cuz you can
defend yourself you're fighting BFC I
have no issue withc slat fighting is I
don't get
that because you can't defend yourself
you're just waiting for someone to hit
you yeah Cal State as athletic
commission unanimously approved by a v
of six to zero for power slap okay you
okay it's like when your doctor's
talking you about vaccines you're like
wait what how do you know okay let's not
talk about that right now okay
yeah uh all right so Strickland did a uh
not YouTube a Instagram video about his
altercation with was he in his truck
Gary he was in his oh you know you know
always in his truck you know some [__]
he coming if he's in that truck there he
is I can't play I kind of truck I don't
even think it's a truck it's just a car
I think it's like Honda or something but
uh he did say a lot of stuff can't play
it even though it's on Instagram
because of the amount of stuff he says I
I don't want us to get flagged okay he
goes I went to the pi today I ran to the
eer cuck Ian Gary god dog dude did you
see what Colby said about Ian yeah he
said the guy likes to watch his wife get
get beat up by another man so he's
goingon to enjoy this you know it's bad
uh I went to Pi today I ran to the F
cuck Ian Gary Strickland said awkward
man awkward he looked at me secured had
to escort escort us around effing
awkward uh poop I'm laughing my butt off
anyway Gary I don't effing hate you dud
actually like you I think you're uh
funny little dweeb you make me effing
laugh and then this is like the main
part I think you're a dumbass effing kid
who got some uh vagina that was too good
for him and he got in his effing and it
effed you up uh it effed you up I look
at you like a victim I don't want you to
fight you bro uh I'm happy for your
success I'm happy for you but if you
look at me hard and you're feeling some
kind of way that you need to get this
poop effing handled you want to look at
me hard and that's what you want slide
up in the DMS bro I don't want it but if
that's what you want you know where to
find me man all this is doing all is
just the Rumblings of this huge mega
fight yeah I maal Gary again huge KO
this Saturday gets on the mic goes Lon
I'll get to you strain you're next you
want to talk all this stuff about my
wife and say I'm a cuck I'll show you a
cuck boom UFC right I mean it's already
building like
crazy uh this one I thought
was I don't know how to feel about this
one so it's not loading but so Ian
Machado Gary saying that he he would
like to come to America to watch UFC 296
but he's afraid for his family watch you
mean have his family watch no no to to
come here to watch the actual fights to
go with his family to the fights UFC 296
isn't he fighting it but his family his
family yeah sorry not him his family his
family uh but he's saying like he's
worried that because of all the hate
that's online he's worried about his
wife and his kid yeah because it's not
the same thing it's not trust me and
these haters won't do [__] you know it's
just fun to do online they're not going
to do anything to your family I get how
again it's your family so you don't even
risk it uh if I'm him I probably
wouldn't bring him just in case just be
safe it's also much easier and less one
less thing you have to worry about just
leaveing at home yeah or or or have them
watch it in a in a dope spot in Vegas
you know but I wouldn't bring him to the
arena if it's cuz one more thing that
you have to worry about going to this
massive fight is true so just set them
up in Vegas so when you get done you can
see your family that's the move yeah but
I think this kind of haes more like
they're just disappointed in him you
know not like actually hating on his
family just don't like his girl yeah I
wouldn't be worried if um because it's a
personal issue so so no one actually
it's something fun to run on and
obviously he's this super arrogant guy
which he should be as a fighter and so
him being a cuck like the whole MMA Real
Housewives Community they can jump on
that the story of last week it's already
dying down if he gets a win that
completely dies down I would be more
worried if I was Kobe Covington because
people are so stupid they actually think
he's that guy than him being this huge
Trump guy and the people on the left
especially the extreme left like when
Kobe gets a bomb threat he should
probably take it serious because then
you're talking about extremist yeah even
Machado Gary doesn't have extremist he
has trolls big difference there's a big
difference when you go from trolls
online where they they live for this
kind of content and they're going to
make clicks and they want to make money
that's different those people are
harmless they're they're just they don't
have skills so that's why they do that
but when you're talking about extremist
when it comes to political issues that's
different if I'm kby that's something I
would be worried about that's when you
need security that's when you need to I
probably shouldn't bring my family like
Kobe done I don't know if he has a girl
I don't know what's going on but I'm
with you on that TI for sure big
difference
those extremist yeah big difference yeah
Kobe said some crazy stuff so yeah and
Kobe goes there you go I've had death
threats bombings people want to kill me
after Brazil I've never turned off my
social media never turned off my
comments look at the little Ian Gary
He's turn off his comments like a little
effing sensive soy boy you know he ain't
tough he ain't the biggest and baddest
fighter in the division the guy's a
effing joke he's a little effing kid so
I don't really have anything to say to
him I'm I'm I'm telling you these guys
are off these guys are off they're going
to learn you're going to [__] around and
find out e Machado Gary's that guy he
has all the skill too he's a bad mother
trucker you're gonna find
out
yeah okay um so this popped up recently
so Henry Henry cejudo versus Mor Deval
great fight for Anaheim here great fight
great fight you see 298 so curious with
that phenomenal fight and another dude
how about we didn't even talk about our
boy uh Otani Dodgers 700 I was going to
save that for d k but Bri didn't know
what the Dodgers are little alone Otani
but the money is insane mhm yeah the
most ever right yeah biggest contract in
sports of all time yeah even more than
LeBron that's crazy almost double LeBron
yeah nuts so cool I didn't think he was
going to the Dodgers I'm more of a
Padre's guy I was hoping You' go to the
Padres or Cubs
but's been on record saying he doesn't
like the Dodgers like years ago he like
I'd never go to the Dodgers I don't like
what they represent I want to go
somewhere the Money Talks Money Talks
yeah he's like I actually love the
Dodgers uh yeah anyway uh so this is a
report I think this is I it might be
official now but it's a report that uh
Jack Dela Melina is GNA fight uh Gilbert
Burns o doggy 299 Jack Del JDM another
one of my favorites another up and comer
that's what I love top fight for Gilbert
TP fight for Jack that's a great
freaking fight for sure um next one this
well this is kind of okay this is a
quick one Han get knocked out versus
Drew Derber yeah you drew Dober but this
one was the big news so this guy his
name is robell despain um the last three
fights that he had uh it's a total of 19
seconds he knocked everyone out damn it
says he knocks him dude out in 4 seconds
yeah and he's 6'7 clearly heavyweight so
the UFC signed him right away think mck
mayard is the one that signed him right
away heavyweight he's yeah yeah sure six
seven wel you know these are crazy man
he's heavyweight so uh yeah Fury FC
Jesus his last three fights CL combine
total time of 19 seconds he has to
what's his background he have technique
tewo so he's a bronze medalist in 2012
for tewo this kid's a problem how's that
takedown defense though that's what's
great about the UFC find out
yeah but he's a killer so far
oh and also his wingspan I I want to
show you this so you know Jon Jones I
think I think Jon Jones even yeah even
beat St St he has 87 holy
Nikes what are they going to do with
this guy who's gonna fight him
first longest reach in UFC history he's
around four to five people wide Jesus
Christ crazy this guy's going to be a
problem but again what's his Jitsu like
what's his wrestling like cuz these guys
live that's why the UFC will show him
yeah that's that's why it's always dice
when he's this green behind the
ears it's tough but at least heavyweight
you don't have to win a ton to get a
title
shot um so there is rumors about
remember I think we talked about it on
the last episode but Kevin Holland and
Michael Venom page the whole thing on
the ne boys podcast whatever so anyway
so Michael Venom page was at uh the pfl
and then he faced off with Cedric Cedric
dbe who's like one of the craziest k out
there so there's talk about him
potentially signing with the pfl and not
the UFC and that would be a shame that'd
be a shame yeah so Kevin Holland said if
he did that it's it's a money thing and
he respects it he's 100 he's 100% right
it's just a money thing as far as the
Legacy thing like I want see him against
the very best that Dumba guy phenomenal
best best Prospect by far pfl's ever had
UFC dropped the ball on that one but if
he goes there it's like all you get this
one fight and then you're the guy that
was a stud in Bellator in in
pfl
yeah I mean let me ask you real Qui okay
you real quick like if you're in the
same position you're getting this much
money here where legacy's here what do
you
do um I would have to know what the
UFC's are now if the UFC's low ball I'm
give them like 30 and 30 then yeah this
a no-brainer but I imagine that Michael
page level they're offering decent money
especially with everything going on
outside the UFC with that lawsuit
they're probably going to give him a
fair offer so uh if I'm Michael Venom
Paige I I would want to see how I
compete against the very best in the
world and po there's no doubt without a
[__] doubt in my mind the very best
are not in the pfl they're not in
Bellator they're just not so if he wants
to play with the big boys and and really
test his skill you got to sign with the
UFC otherwise it's a money and you want
easy matchups and fun matchups and do
your thing but you'll never be
considered the best and I would assume a
guy like microen page wants to see where
he lines up against the very best well
here's your
opportunity yeah makes sense
uh so there was there was a rumor
circulating yeah that someone made about
rumor FF Nick
Diaz soor that caught fire George St
Pier said he's like absolutely not doing
it cuz he's not after 40 he doesn't want
to fight in anything like MMA related
but he would compete still St and some
other stuff hey okay George okay I see
what you're
doing so it's still it's going dude all
right
I don't believe any of these
guys
interesting uh Islam makev said he
doesn't want a
rematch with Charles Olivera he'd rather
fight Justin gatei interesting I mean
yeah I can see that but I don't think
the UFC is G give him a
choice I I would watch either he's he's
in a weird spot uh 55 is in a weird
weird
spot there's no like new Young crop of
guys right now another quick one if this
loads yeah I'm about to piss my pants
you got to yeah I got to pee hard okay
so let me look at what's the best ones
here but real quick remember this kid
you cover this you talk about
this I
knew I think we could play this video
too cuz it's this kid from a while ago
uh oh yeah I remember that kid yeah he
was in the press conference at at the
UFC he's like he's like saying like I'm
going to make it to the UFC and do this
and that so was that during like Conor
uh yes Conor was there yeah so here I'll
play this clip I'm sure this is fine
we'll see yeah
yeah wait hold on
SEC let's
refresh let's hear it Dam I'm going to
be the new breed of the UFC I love
it I love it what's your
proposition Dan I'm time National KB
Champion I'm Irish and British champion
at Jiu-Jitsu and I'm a world medalist at
kickboxing so I'm guaranteed that you're
going to be strapping that gold belt
around my
waist welcome to
[Music]
the
[Applause]
yes
so on my first paychecks
for what' he say to
see his accent's so hard to to get but
um the main thing he said was like uh
make this is when Jose Aldo was fighting
Conor McGregor he's like uh spit shine
that belt for Conor McGregor and now
this kid is uh he won his pfl debut in
Europe what yeah he's fighting now yeah
hold on computer super slow that's him
right now and he did I think a
guillotine win in pfl yeah pfl Europe I
think they do amateur and professional
so I think he's I think he's still
amateur that's cool though man that's
great yeah what a
story
um actually before we do this
one nah we're good all right
so this is a senator in uh Ireland oh
she messed up going after Conor she did
did and she she got lit up hopefully my
computer's good to go anyway she she
said that she wouldn't even like elect
or nominate Connor to wash dishes and
then he went off on her he goes I
nominate you to brush your teeth and see
the dentist because there was a cause to
bring back mask I would call for it it's
so freaking funny anyways all right I
don't have to play it and he says like
something about Ginger vitis it's super
super funny yeah she got L up I mean
what' you
expect you know what the computer's not
doing that well right now so let's go
ahead and I think we're good to go there
yeah that's Tyrone Spong by the way he
looks so different oh wow he looks
cool looks like a scar from Lion King
yes he does that's sick all right kids
UFC 296 goes down this freaking Saturday
we have a live fight campaign with
Cheeto Vera Rampage and myself starts at
700 p.m live on thick boy YouTube you
got vente luk in Gary Tony Fen Patty
piml shot Wonderboy Thompson panta
Brandon Roy Val your co-main event then
Leon Edwards Kobe comington get you some
this is the fight card of all fight
cards and it's a great way to end the
year so make sure you tune in to the
fight companion live at 700 PM Pacific
on thick boy touring wise uh I have a
little bit of a break I'll be around La
but next up is Nashville January 25th
and Austin January 26 27th get your
tickets at thick boy
.c uh for Toontown we got we got a bunch
of stuff coming this week uh the episode
will drop the second episode will drop
this month so we'll keep you posted it's
coming soon stay patient having some
issues with the lightning but it's
coming fam love you guys be nice to each
other stay safe happy holidays see you
next
time